this year's going to be a spoiler free
section of my review spoiler free go see
the flash because it's awesome from now
on in this video we're going to talk
about some spoilers you have then warn
the flash so the flash is another DC
comic book property on the CW like era
and unlike arrow which has started to
beat her in my enjoyment of it flash as
it went on simply got better and better
and better throughout the season
culminating in the season finale in
which I swear to God I teared up like
three times in that one episode was
excellent so in the flash Barry Allen's
is really likable forensic scientist
dude he gets nailed by a lightening
bullet cuz this particle accelerator was
going off and then all Sims like oh I'm
the flash and this sounds like a simple
a superhero premise I always thought
that about the flash of like dudes fast
so then I started reading DC comic books
I was like oh there's more to him than
that see the flash as it was gray bit to
get going and know some of my fans on
Twitter were like I watch the flash for
a couple episodes and then I just kind
of dropped it I will say the first few
episodes of the flash are kind of freak
of the week it's like every week has a
villain we're still a particle
accelerator made someone kind of like a
superhuman it reminded me kind of like
Smallville owes like be careful guys
don't backslide in all that we have
progressed in in television
entertainment over the course of the
past decade and a half then he starts
dealing with reverse flash and then
every episode just gets better and
better and better and better see what I
love about this show is it's like season
one the writers just poured everything
into season one I was like they're
probably gonna bring the whole
time-travel thing in season two right
maybe season three No halfway through
season one but flash was running and
that other flash was right next to me
like oh they're gonna do time which by
application of reverse flash even being
in the show they're doing time already
and they does and it's so cool to even
the characters in this show that I
didn't think I would really end up
liking I ended up loving Cisco it's like
the most relatable one to me I know we
all want to be the cool when we all want
to be the awesome one we all want to be
the one who gets the chick but in the
end I relate most of Cisco because I got
all of Cisco's movie references so that
woman episode where you bar thong just
start spilling the beans tomb and then
like
the collie mouth thing and crushes his
heart I honestly thought he was toast so
when Barry Allen ended up going back I
was like oh he's gonna change it
thank God cuz I thought Cisco was dead I
loved Joe in the show I even liked his
Eddie you're like are you a douchebag
are you like a nice dude by the end of
the show you're like rooting for Eddie
you're like Eddie get there sorry Barry
I don't know what to say
that is so nice and I knew his last name
and I was like is he reverse-flash or
say how are they doing that no one
episode were reverse-flash goes face to
face with him and throws him down he was
like why didn't he kill me I was like
I just want I can talk about the season
finale alone for like 30 minutes so I'm
gonna try to do it in a couple the
season finale of this show if you don't
want hardcore spoilers this is where you
turn off the video the season finale
it was the most satisfying season finale
I have seen in television in a very long
time everything just worked with it had
so many Easter eggs and so much
resolution I mean I was watching it I
was like if I were writing the show I
would have Eddie straight-up sacrifice
shoot himself because Eddie is eobard
thawne's aggregor great-grandfather
shoots himself
eobard thawne never exists this
never happens and I was like they're not
gonna do that so I will end up talking
about how I would have done it in my
video and then it happens and Eddie
straight-up does it and I was like oh my
god oh my god shows like it's my brain
or I'm in its brain or someone's in
someone's perfect that's how you do it
it's what you do and I loved like
everything y'all did like when the black
hole opens up and jay garrick's helmet
comes crashing out of there jay garrick
it's like the original flash like 1940
yeah Bart thawne's like that's my cue to
go I was like what all right so all this
all year long does tell my brother
almost like dude there's so many flashes
they could bring them all in Barry Allen
Bart Allen Wally West Jay Garrick all
these speedsters with the Speed Force
and are they doing the thing where Jay
Garrick is trapped in the Speed Force in
which case when the black hole opens up
and Barry Allen goes up in there as Jay
Garrick and a pop out is Barry Allen
gonna go in an alternate timeline when
he's running through the timeline you
see like all the past president featured
everything just like flashing in front
of me you see a bunch of stuff I'm not
gonna mention all of it cuz it's
probably gonna slip my mind but you see
the flash Museum you see killer frost
which is Caitlin snow it's one scene
where Barry Allen's like in hand
cuffs in jails all this cool that
may or may not happen because you bar
thong keeps saying like the futures like
a possible future which the big question
is like why did that black hole just end
up popping up after eobard thawne just
disappeared from existence I've seen and
heard a bunch of different theories
about it one is that Jay Garrick you
know he's coming through did come to our
world another one and this is like kind
of a simple explanation but it reminded
me of legacy Akane's Soul Reaver to
history abhors a paradox if eobard
thawne never existed then this
couldn't have happened keep in mind
everything that has happened in this
flash series so far has been an
alternate timeline
eobard thawne created that black hole
opens up it's just gonna gobble up his
universe it's like if Thawne never
existed this couldn't have happened but
in order for this to keep from happening
eobard thawne had to have existed in
order for Eddie to want to shoot himself
but it's like a hold it's a loop it just
it conflicts it is a paradox as black
holes like screw it come the universe
doesn't exist anymore so is it gonna
undo is eobard thawne coming back is
reverse-flash still going to be part of
flash I don't know because Barry Allen
goes up to the black hole and that's the
last we see of him I want it to be
relevant though I want that black hole
to mean something is gonna piss me off
it's just like this black hole thing
just kind of berry runs around it and it
just goes away it's like all right no
problem no relevance whatsoever I was
really sad when Eddie died those just
that broke my heart
I liked Eddie and now we died but he
went to the black hole which we don't
know what the singularity is is it just
a black hole that crushed his body and
nothingness or is it the gateway to the
Speed Force you're gonna become
something is he not I'll say this if you
Bart Don is alive if a reverse flash
ends up coming back I want him to be the
actor that was Harrison wells I'm used
to that dude being him now like this
other dude fine I'm sure he's just
perfectly fine as an actor but I don't
relate to him as reverse-flash I know
the other guy is reverse-flash guys the
point is here's what the flash did it
showed us that you can still have
comic-book fun with the series in a show
and that can be the show's strength you
don't need to take the flash and bring
it down into the mud and be dark and
brooding like ah I'm the flash there's
so much pain no they kept the flash the
comic book and I love that you know when
people like oh it's too comic book II
for me the flash shows us that's not a
negative you can make that that's okay
because honestly speaking comic books
are pretty friggin cool the flash just
got better and better and better if you
guys can stick with it and get through
about
think it's episode eight or nine where
reverse-flash actually does his thing
for the first time from then on just
becomes like one of the coolest shows
you have on TV it was the show I look
forward to every week I would wake up
and I'm like it's Tuesday oh my god the
flash is on today so if you guys didn't
catch it
so I guess CW is airing the flash like
from the beginning all through summer
time has been reversed for you that or
it'll be on Netflix this fall rest
assured you're gonna get spoilers in the
meantime though although you saw through
this video so you have spoilers so
you'll watch the flash it's excellent
great premise great hero great
supporting cast great villain alright
guys so the flash on CW have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more